عمليات الانقاذ مستمره احد الاطباء في
مدينه
جند دير اسقاله وهي مدينه سوريه قال ان
الفريق الطبي اضطر الى بترساق الطفل طارق
حيدر البالغ من العمر 3 سنوات بعد انقاذه
من تحت
الطبيب وان بقاء الطفل اكثر من اربعين
ساعه تحت الانقاذ تسبب في ضعف الدوره
الدمويه باطرافه
الطفل طارق جمعه حيدر 3 سنوات
لديه تموت في الساق ومنتصر الفخذ الايسر
طبعا تم انقاذه من تحت الردم ادى ذلك الى
نقص ترويه في الطرف السفلي الايسر مع تنخر
بالعضلات مما اضطرنا الى اجراء البدر
حفاظا على حياته حاليا الطرف الايمن ايضا
لديه وزن شديده سنقوم بتحرير الحجرات
والساق
للاطباء دور كبير طبعا ومعنا من منطقه
الدانه في ادلب الشماليه دكتور نهاد عبد
المجيد وهو استشاري جراحه جراحه العظميه
في مستشفى الامل للتخصصي اذا دكتور يعني
هذا ابدا معك من حيث انتهى الطبيب في
التقرير السابق عندما يبقى الشخص محتجزا
لفتره طويله تحت الانقاذ ما هي ابرز
الاثار والعوامل التي تظهر على جسده
ان لم يكن هنالك اصابه مباشره بالطبع
حياكم الله
شكرا على هذه الفرصه لاتاحه وتسليط الضوء
على معاناه الشعب السوري التي يقاسيها منذ
اثار الحرب الحمد لله رب العالمين على
قضاء الله وقدره حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل
ولا حول ولا قوه الا بالله العلي العظيم
بتاريخ
6/2/2023 حوالي الساعه الرابعه ونصف فجرا
كانت كنا على كارثه حقيقيه على المناطق
التي تاثرت في الزلزال ضرب منطقه جنوب
تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا واخص بالذكر منطقه
حارم وسلقين وكذلك منطقه الاتارب بريف حلب
الغربي ومنطقه جنديرس وعفرين كان لدور
الدفاع المدني
هناك كان لديهم
حاولوا بكل الوسائل المتاحه لانتشال الجثث
من تحت الانقاض في جميع المناطق بالنسبه
انا اعمل طبيب جراحه عظمي في مشفى الامل
التخصصي للجراح العظمي والذي يقدم خدماته
بشكل مجاني والمدعوم من قبل منظمه وطن
الخيريه ورد الينا الحالات الاسعافيه
حوالي 1900 شخص بلغ عدد الوفيات حوالي ما
يقارب 75 وفاء
بالنسبه للعمليات الجراحيه التي اجريت
بشكل الاسعافي حوالي 100 حاله مئه عملي
وتم تاجيل عدد من الحالات الى الاسابيع
الاخرى لاستيعاب الحالات الاسعافي طبعا
وصلت حالات متنوعه من بتور للاطراف وتم
اجراء خزع للحجرات كما تتناول الاطباء
زملائي بشكل اسعافي خوفا من تهديد انقطاع
الترويه عن الاطراف السفليه
نعم دكتور يعني صحيح انت مختص بالجراحه
العظميه ولكن على العموم انت طبيب ومنظمه
الصحه العالميه تحذر مما سمته
بكارثه موازيه نتيجه هذا الزلزال وهم طبعا
يتحدثون عن الاوضاع الناجمه عن هذا
الزلزال بالنسبه للناس سواء في سوريا ولا
ام في تركيا
نعم اخي الكارثه كبيره وفوق قدرتنا انتم
تعلمون جيدا وضع سوريا خلال 12 سنه
الماضيه من اثار الحرب ولدينا ضعف حقيقه
حاد بمستلزمات العلاج الطبي من وسائل
الاستيتال الاسياخ الصفائح البراغي كذلك
مستلزمات الدفاع المدني من الجرافات
والادويه
والمواد اللازمه
لانتشال الجثث
نعم دكتور نهاد ما هي ابرز الاحتياجات
الطبيه في هذه المرحله التي تطالبون بها
الاحتياجات التي نعانيها هي على قسمين قسم
خدمات اجتماع خدمات مجتمعيه نحتاج هناك
بحاجمه في الامارات لمراكز ايواء نتيجه
الناس المتضررين والتي تهدمت ابنيتهم
ابنيتهم والذين يحتاجون الى تقديم كذلك
الطعام واللباس اما بالنسبه على الصعيد
الطبي نحتاج مواد استجدال جراحيه نحتاج
كذلك الادويه من الصادات الحيويه
والمسكنات واجهزه التعقيم والتصوير الشرعي
كان على سبيل المثال بالنسبه لمشفىنا
الدكتور لا ادري اذا كنت فقط يعني تساهم
في علاج من ياتون الى المشفى عندكم ام انك
ساهمت في عمليات الانقاذ ولكن في كل
الاحوال اود ان تحدثنا عن دور الاطباء
بحكم تخصصك ايضا في عمليه الانقاذ ما الذي
يراعونه حتى يعني يتاكدوا من سلامه الشخص
الذي يحاولون ان ينتشلوه والا يتعرض لمزيد
من الضرر
الحقيقه الاطباء في منطقه شمال غرب سوريا
في منطقه ادلب استنفروا وكانوا فيهم
متوزعين في جميع المشافي على جميع النقاط
التي تضررت الحقيقه هناك الكثير من
الحالات التي وردت على مستوى كان بثور
الاطراف طبعا المريض لما بيجي بيتم فحصه
بشكل عام من قبل بالمشفى لعده ممكن عده
ساعات اذا كانت الحيويات جيبي مستقره
بيتخرج بعدين على ممكن مراكز استشفاء اخرى
للمراقبه والحالات اللي بتحتاج لتداخل
جراحيه يتم اجراءها بشكل اسعاف
طيب دكتور نهاد يعني من وحي خبرتك ومن
المعلومات المتوفره لديك كطبيب الى متى
يمكن ان يصمد الانسان دون غذاء ودون ماء
تحت انقاض مبنى ما
في كثير حالات اجتنا يعني اطفال بعد
تقريبا حوالي 35 ساعه ثلاث اطفال بعمر
حوالي 3 سنوات كانوا احياء الحمد لله وحتى
ما كان فيهم لكن الانسان لما بينقطع عنه
الهواء يعني ما بجوز دقائق او عده حوالي
ساعه يتوفى الشخص
طيب يعني ايضا اذا تشرح لنا طبيا يعني انه
احيانا نسمع عن شخص مثلا 70 وتجاوز وجوده
اكثر من 60 او 90 ساعه ويتمكنون من
انتشاله وهو على قيد الحياه وهو ما يبدو
وكانه في الحقيقه
معجزه لمن يسمع ويرى ولكن ان كان بالامكان
ان تشرح لنا انت كيف يحدث ذلك من الناحيه
الطبيه
لرجل في مثل هذا السن
الحقيقه اولا اولا اخيرا الفضل لله سبحانه
وتعالى في بقاء مثل هذه مثل هيك حالات انه
على قيد الحياه هدول بكون غالبا يعني
محجوزين انه بين كتل الاسمنتيه غير ضاغطه
على الجسم يعني الصدر حركات التنفس وحركات
القلب تجري بشكل جيد دون اي ضغط عليها
بيكون مقطوع فقط عنهم الطعام والشراب
بيكون القلب والتنفس شغال
شكرا جزيلا شكرا جزيلا لكم من منطقه
الدانه في ادلب الشماليه دكتور نهاد عبد
المجيد وهو استشاري جراحه عظميه في مستشفى
الامن التخص